welcome back actor Kevin Spacey has
found not liable in his sexual
misconduct case brought by actor Anthony
Rapp jurors deliberated for about an
hour and a half before handing down the
verdict Rappel into space he sexually
assaulted him back in 1986 when he was
only 14 years old he said a then 26 year
old Spacey invited him back to his
Manhattan apartment after that rap says
Spacey laid him down on a bed and
pressed his groin onto his body all
without consent before the trial began
the judge dismissed raps claim of
assault and later the claim of
intentional infliction of emotional
distress jurors were then left to
deliberate on the battery claim during
the trial rap testified the alleged
event was quote the most traumatic
single event of his life Spacey also
took the stand denying the allegations
and broke down crying to describe
growing up with a Neo-Nazi father
Spacey's attorneys argued rap created a
story because he was jealous of Spacey's
career Spacey faces separate sexual
assault charges and out of the United
Kingdom that trial is expected to begin
in June of 2023.
Terry in the age of the metoo movement
were you shocked of the verdict here and
could gender have played a role in
believing rap in this case
well I don't know if gender played a
role I wasn't really shocked by the
verdict itself but I was really
surprised by how fast the jury came back
with that verdict it's one of the
fastest I've seen a little over an hour
I think as far as the outcomes concerned
maybe part of the reason the jury did
not believe rap was because it happened
so long ago and though they should not
be considering that exactly because
there are reasons people don't come out
I think the amount that he was asking
you know the 40 million they may have
thought that that was astronomical My
Hope Is that they came back to the right
conclusion I do think that this is
something that rap was trying to do for
the metoo movement I think he said that
after the verdict he said he was going
to continue to fight on these causes and
so you know as I said the jury just came
back so quickly I do hope that they
looked at all of the evidence and that
they carefully considered it now Bernard
I believe prosecutor in Philly I know
Brooklyn you were Prosecuting as well
now to defense attorney welcome to the
dark side uh what does a verdict in the
about 90 minutes tell you about how the
jury evaluated this case
well then it was an easy one for the
jury especially when you're thinking
that this case was not a criminal case
meaning that there wasn't the burden of
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt but it was a
civil case by preponderance of the
evidence was it more likely that the
charges were actually proving 51 to 49
so for the jury to come back so quickly
just goes to tell you that they did not
have any doubt in terms of The
credibility of Kevin Spacey and they
found that it was without Merit and
therefore they returned the verdict that
they thought was correct based on the
evidence that was presented but I think
it had a lot to do with Kevin Spacey
actually testifying he came off a better
witness than the actual complainant in
the place yeah 90-minute win I can't
disagree with that thank you both also
in Celebrity legal news a jury is seated
in the trial of disgrace movie Mogul
Harvey Weinstein the jury made up of
nine men and three women were chosen
from a pool of more than 200 people
eight alternates were also seated and
sworn in 73 year old Weinstein is
charged with 4K accounts of rape and
seven more of sexual assault out of Los
Angeles he has pled not guilty to all
charges Weinstein is already serving a
23-year sentence for a separate rape in
a sexual assault conviction out of New
York the California trial is expected to
last more than six weeks opening
statements are expected to be presented
on Monday
coming up along